من الاسكندريه الى عامل التوصيل محمد سعد
اهلا بك يا محمد معنا في صباح العربيه
محمد سمعني
يسعد صباحك يا محمد ازيك
اغضب الزبون تحديدا انت اكثر
والله
كان في حدود الساعه 1:30 بالليل
واحده ونصف بالليل
فقال لي صح البواب فالمهم راح البواب ما
البواب ما رضاش يصحى البوابه ما رضيش يصحى
المهم رحت قلت له يا فندم مش راضي يسكت
قال لي انا هانزل لك اربع تدور على رجلي
المهم قفلت التليفون واخذت بعدي ورحت طالع
فوق وطلعت لغايه باب الشقه عمال اخبط عمال
اخبط عليه عمال اخبط عليه ما فيش عمال ارن
على الجرس ما فيش بارن له على التليفون ما
فيش بعد كده راح متصل حضرتك بالمطعم
وقال له
[موسيقى]
الو الو تعال خذ خذ التيار قدام الباب اصن
بعدين هاضربه
المهم
اتصلوا بيا قلت له قلت له يا باشا انا
طلعت بالاردن اربع ادوار
ورنيت عليه وهو مش عايز ياخذ الاوردر قال
لي طب تعالى في الاردن المهم راجعت
بالاوردر
خصم علي خصم علي الاوردر
160 جنيه
بيقلي امشي
ثاني يوم اه ثاني يوم قال لي
راح بيتصل بي قال لي تعال
بعد ما قال لي تعال رحت الشغل
صورني
على فيسبوك
انت مش متوصل طلبيه يا محمد
للزبون صار في تلاسم بينكم في التليفون
قبل ما توصل له الطلبيه ليش زعل ما فتح
الباب
انا طلعت له يا فندم طلعت له فوق طلعت له
وخبطت عليه يعني انا خلاص خلصت معه
المكالمه رحت طالع على طول
لغايه باب الشقه خبطت وعملت همم ما رضاش
ياخذ الاوردر
المطعم اتصل بيا قال لي تعال في الاردن
وبعد كده رحت راجعت المطعم خذ مني
خذ خذ
160 جنيه
وبعد كده ثاني
لما هو الراجل صاحب الاوردر صاحب الاوردر
قدم شكوى
فيها
قدم شكوى فيا
فهو اللي مقدم حتى شكوى فربنا سبحانه
وتعالى خلى الجماهير
اتعطفت معايا
والحمد لله رب العالمين كله انا بشكر كل
واحد وكل شاب وكل بنت وكل ولد حط في كلمه
في حقي كلمه كويسه شكرا جزيلا لك
انا راجل عندي 65 سنه
المهم رحت
ثاني يوم راح راح
مصوريني على
الجروب
والناس كلها الحمد لله رب العالمين الناس
كلها واقفه معايا والناس كلها دعمتني
شكرا جزيلا لك من الاسكندريه عامل توصيل
محمد سعد شكرا يا محمد